hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 4 service and this episode
brought things home to Alexandria and I
cannot think of a worse nut check for
Rick than taking all of his guns burning
the place he pox on and revealing that
he is not the father but this episode
was surprisingly packed with little
Easter eggs and interesting connections
back to other episodes so I'm gonna
point out all the stuff you missed and
let's get started with the opening
images now one thing that surprised me
about this episode was that it totally
skipped the immediate aftermath of Rick
and the rest returning home telling the
others what happened instead it jumps
ahead a few days and this opening shot
tells us a lot about where the
characters are now so look at Rick and
Michonne here last season when we saw
them waking up in a bed together they
were posed together in a loving embrace
now they are completely turned away from
each other huge gap between them it's
like Jesus snuck in there the middle of
night and was like hey now you do
lovebirds save room for Jesus yeah no
one is getting any action here so this
physical separation represents the
emotional distance between these two
characters now with Rick being forced
into submission by negan and Michonne
wanting to fight and we'll see how this
change to their sex life or lack thereof
takes a little reform at the end of the
episode moving on to this shot of a
Morse code alphabet on the wall now I
actually have a theory about why this
could be important which I'll get to
when we get to that part of the episode
but for now hang on to that pot I was
actually surprised to see that Michonne
still has her sword considering she was
definitely carrying it when the Savior's
captured her last season and they
confiscated Rick and everyone else's
weapons so you think one of those
Savior's would have been like I want
that I don't they say morale so my
thinking is is that negan is okay with
letting his subjugated people keep
simple weapons like Rick's axe or the
speaker's we saw at the hilltop and I
guess Michonne soared but letting people
keep guns requires more trust like what
they seem to have with the kingdom
either way I'm glad to see Michonne
still with it because that sword is part
of her personality and I think that shot
of the nails on the wall from when she
hung it up in season 5 hoping to never
use it again this shot is meant to
remind us of how much the sword is
reflection of Michonne's fierceness and
resolve and that she cannot part ways
with it
I feel like Michonne should like name
the sword the way negan named Lucille so
what do we think gum
daughter kebab that's a bit of a
mouthful how about Mashona
and before i move on it's also
interesting to see Michonne practicing
her sharp shooting with this sniper
rifle now if you read the comics you've
probably noticed that Michonne is now
kind of being adapted from the comic
version of Andrea Andrea is still alive
at this point and she's a tough advisor
and romantic interest for Rick and she's
also the best sniper in the group so if
Michelle does go in that direction this
would bring that adaptation full circle
okay moving on now I pointed this out
before but negan's arrival with his
silhouette on the gate as he knocks on
it with Lucille and in his line little
pig little pig let me and this is all
taken directly from the comics and it's
such a cool menacing moment that I'm
really glad that they included in the
show but there's a few things I want to
talk about with negan's greeting first
noticed how much Spencer pisses him off
by not knowing his name
ah who are you oh you better be joking
now remember negan considers himself
this godlike figure he loves to put the
fear of the Old Testament into his
subjects and not being recognized is
like a huge blow to his ego and the
reason I bring this up is notice how
when negan takes out this Walker he
mentions the episodes title what I just
did that is some service
now the word service carries some
Sabbagh liqu meaning in this episode
like it could just refer to a tennis
serve which is kind of what negan does
to this Walker but for negan his idea of
service connects to his god complex
because in Christianity service refers
to the idea of the actions you take to
actively express your faith this can be
through offerings like the collection
play or by using your talents to do your
part
just like how Eugene is to simply in
that radio and I'm doing my part service
actually comes up throughout the Bible
and it's reflected in this line from the
Old Testament
be sure to fear the Lord and serve Him
faithfully with all your hearts consider
what great things he has done for you
and this is exactly how negan sees
himself doing these great things for
Rick and demanding Rick to fear and
serve Him now I should say that I know I
bring up religion a lot in these
breakdowns and that's not coming from me
I'm not trying to convert anyone
I'd rap the walking dead show uses
Christian symbolism all the time with
Bible quotes and Glenn's Christ imagery
and Gabriel being a way bigger character
on the show than in the comics so is
something on the show seems like it has
a religious connection it's probably
intentional also it's important to note
that negan is not God this is just how
he sees himself he's an egomaniacal man
with this huge superiority complex and
the way he does this unnecessary favor
as a way to justify appreciation it's
actually a classic manipulative behavior
psychologists have noticed in
Psychopaths like I did this for you even
though you didn't ask me to so now you
owe me that's actually how I make all my
friends wait a minute all my friends are
manipulating me I'm a pawn I'm a pawn
before I move on from the scene I want
to talk about Daryl here this is
actually kind of cool as the camera cuts
back and forth between close-ups of him
and Rick check out Daryl's blinking now
a lot of people are saying that Daryl
might be blinking in Morse code and that
could be why we saw that Morse code
chart and Rick's living room it would
mean that Rick might understand Morse
code and this could be a way they could
secretly communicate now I don't know
Morse code but anonymous experts online
say they do and this isn't confirmed but
they claim the blinking translates to
riot if they kill me now I don't know if
I buy that we don't actually see much of
Daryl blinking across all the scenes
this episode to get that many letters
and why would he want them to riot if he
died like he's not a martyr now another
online Morse code expert translated this
as I yeast which makes a little more
sense because that could be the general
direction of the sanctuary so viewers if
any of you know Morse code please
confirm this for me and tell me what
it's like to be a time traveler from a
hundred years ago or have a ton of free
time on your hands okay moving on to
this shot of negan after the credits for
the camera weirdly zooms out we almost
never see this kind of shot in the
walking dead
it feels kind of loose in almost comedic
and that's because it's the exact kind
of on-the-fly camera movement used in
documentary filmmaking and it really
became a common trope on shows like The
Office and Parks and Rec and with those
who's the boss references last episode
negan is really making the walking dead
a lot more sacani
now I mentioned in my last breakdown
that we never see negan separate from
Lucille and it's interesting how negan
proved me wrong this episode making Rick
hold Lucille so why does he do this on
one level it's about controlling Rick
forcing him to hold the weapon that
killed his friends as a way to keep him
in submission but there's another
creepier reason that connects to that
idea of service that I'll come back to
let's move on to Michonne
trying to shoot this Walker but missing
and hitting this deer instead this is a
cool callback to season two when Rick
Shane and Karl are hunting that deer and
then Karl gets shot suddenly when Otis
shoots through the deer there's a few
reasons for this callback obviously the
episode wants to remind us of Shane and
that idea of these characters actions
echoing moments from the past but also I
think this deer getting shot is meant to
connect us to Karl in that moment
specifically how Rick reacted worried
that he would lose his son in the same
way I think this episode is designed to
return Rick to that place of fear for
his family and speaking of callbacks to
past episodes check out the soda-can
that negan pulls out of the cooler that
looks like an orange crush in fact I'm
guessing it's the same kin that Denise
found for Tara right before she died
last season so negan taking two sips
from it and tossing it aside kind of
suggests that Denise died in vain which
is super sad negan's even an [ __ ]
when he doesn't mean to be but also I
think the show bringing back this Orange
Crush
is meant to remind us of that Orange
Crush Theory remember that was the one
that stated that Denise finding this can
of Orange Crush and then shortly after
dying in the same exact way that Abraham
died in the comics was a clue that that
Orange would soon be crushed which is
exactly what happened so it's really
cool to see the show confirm the theory
like this I also liked how the show
brought back those video camera
recordings from season 5 that was Rick
at the peak of his badassery after he
spent weeks as a drifter killing
everyone and turning himself into
Grizzly Adams and that version of Rick
is meant to be a stark contrast to the
soft broken-down man he is now that's
actually why we see negan recording over
the old Rick with this new version of
Rick basically erasing the tough guy
that he used to be and then Gabriel
plays a really interesting role this
episode so first notice how he scares
negan do you care to pay your respects
Oh
léa crap and yeah sure negan's right
Gabriel is pretty creepy but this points
to the theory that I had that negan
being this false God figure just like
the devil
negan gets freaked out by a true man of
faith so why does he tell negan that
Maggie's dead even when it's far too
quickly dig an empty grave and then
refill at the moment the Savior's
arrived which is why Rick spots some
wiping dirt off his pants later so I
think this shows some smart quick
thinking by Gabriel when negan arrived
Gabriel knew that negan would wonder why
that sick woman wasn't here now and
rather than sent negan off to the
totally undefended hilltop it would be
easier to protect Maggie and her unborn
baby
if negan thinks she's dead now this
seems like a smart plan until the
Savior's realized they've been lied to
so be careful Gabriel you might actually
burn for this now another character
making a big gamble was Carl and it's
interesting how just like Daryl punching
negan leading to Glenn's death
Carl's act of defiance leads directly to
negan making things way worse again
taking all the guns in Alexandria this
reinforces Rick's fear of the
consequences of rebellion against negan
this is the second time Rick came
dangerously close to losing a son now
fast-forwarding bit through this episode
to this scene in the church when Rick's
trying to find out who has the two
missing guns now first off Hey look Enid
made it out of that closet after all
good for you in it but also check out
how Rick is facing the same struggle
trying to convince his people to give up
that real life war leaders have to do
when they sign the terms of surrender at
the end of war like it's a separate
battle to try to convince your people to
agree to that defeat in fact notice how
when Rick says I'm not in charge anymore
negan is he walks backwards he's
literally retreating as he admits to be
moving on to a few more callbacks later
in this episode Rick knows that Spencer
has a guns because Spencer did the same
thing last season stealing from the
pantry when he assumed no one else would
notice looking out for himself remember
Rick Grimes has that investigative
police training which makes it really
easy to determine if someone is a
gutless dumbass also I love this
callback with Enid in those green
balloons now remember back in episode 7
of last season she and Glenn uses
balloons as a way to signal the others
and then shortly after that Glen said
this to her people you love they made
you who you are they're still part of
you so Enid is keeping these balloons as
a way to remember Glenn it's
small moment but it's a really sweet way
to show that she still thinks about him
and she still remembers what he taught
her okay moving on so last episode
seemed to imply that Darrell still had
some fight in him because he refused to
say negan's name so why now has Darrell
gone pretty much completely reek say
nothing refusing to take his motorcycle
back or stay announced Andrea who maybe
his blinking will tell us just turned in
Farben oh it's just gibberish
he's just blinking what a surprise Brie
although I think Darrell might be
playing a part here he knows that if he
can play by negan's rules for right now
he might gain enough trust to officially
join negan's gang and then work as a
kind of double agent for Rick and his
people which is kind of something that
happens with another character in the
comics falou soon to tell but we'll see
then as negan leaves he tells Rick this
messed up line which the censors are
surprisingly okay with I just slit my
dick down your throat and you thanked me
for now
that's another moment taken directly
from the comics and it connects to that
service theme that I brought up earlier
so this line along with the image of
Rick holding Lucille it all has this
gross sexual connotation to it like Rick
has spent this entire episode
servicing negan see not all
interpretations of the show or pious and
saintly some are super dirty and then
real quick check out this mis'able
detail when the Savior's fans drive over
these two Walker's the wheel goes over
one of their heads crushing it so why
did the show go to the trouble for this
effect
that's because negan and the show wanted
these two batted down walkers to mirror
the two of Rick's friends that went down
in the same way and then lying there
with their brain spread out on the
ground is a clear reference to the image
when negan left Rick back in the season
premiere this is kind of like negan's
way of saying never forgive it's also
interesting how Rick looks at the sign
outside these gates vengeance for the
plunderers now this could be read as
ironic since Rick and his people were
totally just plundered doing nothing to
defend themselves or you could read it
as foreshadowing promise like eventually
Rick and his people will have their
vengeance but let's talk about this
face-off between Rick and Spencer now we
know from the earlier scene that Spencer
blames Rick for his parents deaths but
Rick calling him weak
triggers this hero complex inside of him
Austin Nichols actually said that he's
been using Spencer's desire to be a
leader like his mother was as the major
inspiration for his character but check
out Rick's cold-blooded response you say
anything like that again to me I'll
break your jaw knock your teeth out
now I love this for a few reasons one
Rick shows us that he can still be a
tough don't with me badass when he needs
to be also when Rick forces Spencer to
respond by saying yes it shows how negan
suppressive threatening ruling style is
starting to affect Rick but here's my
favorite part of this line it's a call
back way back to season two when Rick
says almost the exact same thing to
Shane I wanted to break your jaw let you
choke on your teeth and that second
reminder of Shane is in our mind in this
immediate next scene when Rick drops
this bomb on us about Shane and Judith I
know Judith isn't mine what I can't
believe people are actually shocked by
this the show very heavily implied this
back in season two but I suppose it is a
pretty big deal that Rick has known this
this whole time now Andrew Lincoln has
said in interviews that it was important
for Rick to bring this up right now
because it reveals why he's afraid to
fight negan at this moment he has his
complicated relationship with Judith but
he made the decision to race her as his
own and that decision has made him
particularly protective he wants to see
her grow up into this beautiful female
Jon Bernthal and then one day say to him
masky senton daddy why is Carl's hair
longer than mine but really Michonne's
argument with Rick is triggered by one
thing in particular they took their bed
so this has come full circle with the
opening images the metaphorical image of
their emotional distance implied by
their posture in bed has now become
literal they don't even have a mattress
to have makeup sex on and then the next
scene adds insult to injury the Savior's
didn't even want the mattresses they
just burn them and left them for the
Alexandria's to find so not only has
Rick and Michonne symbolic marriage bed
even though they aren't technically
married been stolen from them that sense
of safety and security that a bed
represents has now been turned to ashes
but I should point out that burning the
mattresses might not just be a pew from
the Savior's remember earlier them so
Dwight poured out Rosita's water partly
as a dick move but also to make it hard
for her to run
and escape to make sure that she has to
come back quickly there's a practical
reason behind it to in the same way I
think burning the mattresses might have
a practical purpose from the savior's
they don't want the people of Alexandria
to be too comfortable and well rested in
case a conflict arises and it's that
conflict that I think these mattresses
are really all about because if you know
classic films this is a pretty clear
reference to the famous line in The
Godfather you're given one message I
want cilantro not it's all-out war we go
to Ikea which means to prepare for war
and it's pretty clear in this moment
that Michonne is ready to go nuclear
which brings us to the closing images so
while Michonne emotionally readies for
battle Rosita takes a more active step
to do her part she finds that bullet
casing from negan's gun earlier in the
episode and asks Eugene to make a bullet
for the empty gun that she found on the
Walker
now some people are pointing out that
negan's Desert Eagle is a 357 magnum Wow
recetas new gun is a 9-millimeter and
whatever bullet Eugene made from that
casing wouldn't totally fit Rosita's but
others online are saying with a little
modification a 357 bullet could fit a
nine-millimeter the point is apparently
a lot of gun enthusiasts love the show
and for all those people an episode
about a new authority figure actually
taking everyone's guns must have been
the scariest Walking Dead episode yet
but the way Rosita challenges Eugene
here
she's clearly finishing the conversation
they had earlier about whether Eugene
was doing his part and this all connects
to that idea of service that I've been
talking about because service isn't just
a word used for god-fearing people
making operations or sexual connotations
there's another type of service being
applied here military service Rosita is
recruiting Eugene for a new war effort
and hopefully with a new supply of
ammunition the people of Alexandria may
be able to answer negan with a new kind
of service okay some lingering questions
one what do you think about the reveal
that Shane is Judith's father personally
I don't know if I needed it but I'm glad
the show did it this way rather than
have Rick's somehow not know and it's
this big reveal later on like having
Rick know all this time makes him
smarter but also a better person for
loving Judith all the same and - do you
think it was a good idea for Gabriel to
lie to negan about Maggie like I get why
he wants to protect Maggie but I just
don't really see negan do anything bad
to a pregnant woman but if the Saviour
ever find out which based on the promos
for next episode go getters where they
go to the hilltop and Maggie's there
realizing he's been lied to could be
something that triggers negan to take
some kind of sick punishment I don't
know we'll see if this game ball pays
off okay thanks for watching and let me
know what you think in the comments and
check out my breakdown to the first
three episodes of the season as well and
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share this video with all
your Walking Dead friends you can also
contribute to us on patreon so thanks so
much to all of our current donors
especially Pony Stark thanks pony and if
you are currently a patron we'd love to
have your support you can follow me on
Twitter a da box with any questions or
thoughts you've had on Walking Dead or
you can follow new rockstars on Twitter
at new rock stars okay thanks for
watching bye